So, we're going to talk
about a couple of the U.S.
laws related to cyber crime and
illegal online activities.
The first one is the U.S.
Computer Fraud and
Abuse Act, that's CFAA,
actually goes back a while.
But the goal of this law or
this act, was to define
what is criminal, when it comes
to things that you do online.
So, various types of online abuse.
And then define criminal sanctions
against those kind of actions or
activities.
That constitute abuse or fraud.
So, it really covers unauthorized
access to computers.
So, you're not allowed to be some
place in the physical world,
we have laws like that.
Here we're sort of trespassing
somebody's computer that
is connected to the internet and
we can reach out to it.
So computer obviously has things
of value that you are after.
If you happen to the the cyber criminal,
that's who is being
targeted by this law.
So I said it goes back a while,
initially it was rather net-over
it was trying to protect.
It's sort of multuation came from
national security, national defense.
So, it's saying if you gain
unauthorized access to a computer
that has data related
to national defense.
That is illegal.
This was then extended
to financial data,
because people do care
about their money.
And criminals,
cyber criminals actually after money.
They want to steal
your online account or
steal credit card information and so on.
If you access either defense related or
financial data and
the access is unauthorized.
CFAA says that that's an illegal act.
So, what exactly is unauthorized access?
Unauthorized access essentially,
is getting hold of this data,
gaining access to it.
So remember, when it comes to
data we had the confidentiality,
integrity and availability requirements.
That we had the CIA requirements,
that we had to find when you
talk about securing data.
So, gaining access to it,
you're able to see the data that
you shouldn't be able to see.
Use it, for example,
of financial gain modification is
affecting its integrity, corrupting it.
Destroying is exactly that,
disclosure is to anybody who's not
authorized to see it and so on.
If all this is done when the system
under consideration happens to be
a government system.
Well that's how CFAA started, so
this basically is saying the law
covers access to information.
Modification, we're not allowed to do so
and
using that information in any shape and
form.
Destroying it, affecting availability,
that's what you would do with this,
is illegal.
So, this one initially was
something that is operated by or
on behalf, so it could be
a contractor or the US government.
But this, as a history this was
broadened to include any computer.
The language is any protected computer,
basically a protected computer is any
computer that's connected the Internet.
So, a protected computer,
if you access it without permission, and
gain access to the data, or destroy it.
Or corrupt it while you're
committing an illegal act.
It then actually keeps getting more and
more specific.
Transmitting code or malware, malicious
software that can damage a computer,
well that's illegal as well.
And finally,
it specifically addresses passwords that
I'd use to gain access to computers.
So, if you steal a truckload
of passwords and
want to sell them on the black market,
the underground market.
That's trafficking in
computer passwords and
if you did that,
that would be illegal as well.
So, accessing data that is
not yours in various forms.
Infecting computers with malicious
software, trafficking in passwords that
allow others to gain access to
computers that are protected.
All those things are covered
under the Computer Fraud and
Abuse Act that we have
in the United States.